c'est
[Musique]
on voit très bien ici vous avez le coeur
de l'activité nouvelles aptitudes
donc on va recevoir ici toute la
collecte des facteurs qui vont nous
emmener tout ce qui est papier de bureau
vous recevrez du papier de la poste
c'est ça vous triez ces saloperies il
repart ou chez des papiers pour le
recyclage
[Musique]
le quesnoy arrivée vous desservir voilà
les camions arrivent non des charges
tous les chariots et ensuite on va les
emmener à l'apaiser
ici c'est le poste de pesée on à la
balance qui se trouve là on met les
chariots dessus et ensuite on va rentrer
la provenance du papier on l'est pèse on
les emmène aux hauts-plateaux de tri
alors martigues où vous votre rôle ici
ça alors le rôle actuellement classé de
recevoir un agrément l'écrit couleurs on
sait par le blanc 2 par exemple des
enveloppes kraft comme ceux ci on a des
bacs de récupération pour ça pour le
carton également et tout ce qu'on
appelle gros maquis en fait c'est tout
ce qui est libre mélange de cartes entre
deux tours en gros le sac papier de
voilà est également le plastique on
recycle de l'autre côté qui partira
enchaîne ensuite dans votre cv ni donc
maintenant ce qu'on a travaillé a été
compressé et se retrouve dans des bals
que vous voyez à côté de moi mais ça
valait direct c'est le passé
[Musique]